they don't touch the top my hair they
only do fades hmm so tons of black
people in there bring that back up
please Nick if you notice endless and
the walk when he's sending me this
picture I said bro you have to be in
Mexico that go up a that green color
paint is only in Mexicans actually
called Tijuana
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
on my bag bro dude I just went off
fishing up in Oregon all weekend what
made you go to or given just cruised up
there man
I'd never been up there didn't get a
bite didn't get a fish ran oh oh nothing
you just stared at the water basin
through a [ __ ] oh I'm embarrassing
man lost like thirty dollars worth of
lures in there lura son I don't know
what they say yet Lewis what kind of
fishery I guess looking at I did see one
fish swim by one time know some guy came
over to help us we got so many like
Laura's snagged in the UM and on the
rocks and stuff so basically just ankle
deep in water standing water is insane
man beautiful but it was just
embarrassing did you at least go to
Captain D's after and show him who's
boss there I am right there look at him
go caught nothing out there how many
hours were you out there um I was out
there probably three hours them duck
dynasty vibes huh yeah go forward a
couple Nick on the other side I'm like
[ __ ] honesty subtle ladies a warm and
dry cat food out there we didn't catch
nuttin
dang it warm and dry cat food damn you
have to follow protocol wear that mask
yeah on the plane and see where the mask
the lady said we'll have to everybody
had it on and at one point the lady
looked over at me and went like that
damn cuz
didn't have it on they don't have it on
so I'll put it on I didn't have it on I
was trying to have a snack hard to
breathe it yeah put a snack hole on it
you do something yeah let me snack this
[ __ ] yeah let me drink through it at
least put a little skittle outlet or
something like a sneaker candy yeah put
a little hole in there oh yeah I feel
you I'm saying it saying it to you know
fish dog oh what a waste this time
one guy had three fish and he they were
beautiful man that was shoving your face
a little bit like Jamie's fish are
biting over here man skin annoying
we cannot eat so much I feel like damn I
might have to open up with a query
it's like SeaWorld over in these bins
are you guys doing over there not in man
never seen it did anybody have
experience fishing though fishings a
technique to men
yeah he's splashing around and shouldn't
joking around
yeah I was in the fish dip out you know
Silent Assassin I was real quiet he had
the big big water boots on no no I
wasn't standing in there
I was just sit on the outside sitting on
a bucket I had a couple snacks didn't
even have any snacks I was trying to be
so quiet get that ass fit on a bucket
when you get a snack yeah thank you
snack sometimes yeah sometimes I'm
snackies fish way to oh yeah not
sometimes I'll be snacking I miss entire
shows oh all dialogues really gonna put
the closed caption I'm snacking I'm
watching like Nardo I missed the whole
plotline I spank it snack I can't eat
with somebody like that I can't watch TV
with somebody like that
I can't be ruined someone's eating
really is chewing it you have a child
miss Ophelia are you serious this
ammonia oh the black tape didn't work
you gotta tell me when you break it I
find it on the ground or just 15 minutes
before the show Nick you barely do his
job dude
Nick is the Keith Peterson of you mean I
do my job well when I'm drunk
[Laughter]
this is a every time you get rid of drop
10 bro meet me at 2 4 dude you know you
took with you fishin Shin really yeah
man I was jealous - all those pictures
you - there's two things you want to do
with chin what's what there's two things
you want to do with them the other one
but it's if you if you want to go eat
cream barbecue chin
yep if you want to go fishing you take
this channel why you want to hide a dead
body
you call chin oh damn huh those three
things really what do you fish for chin
actually when I was looking at your
thing I fish for trout mostly so looks
like that's trattoria yeah if the fresh
is a freshwater if yeah this freshwater
pressure you can imagine mmm so fresh
drinking it oh yeah you could pick some
up in just hand
love the free water man it would jump
right any if you even open your mouth up
close about six inches from the top of a
lake someone would jump oh yeah just
that Oregon [ __ ] River man food
coming right out the mountains beautiful
[Laughter]
middle seat over there
like I'm on Spirit Airlines my penis
we got chairs in here you got another
one oh hell no this the original the
wheels fall don't use electrical tape
Jim what tips would you gave Co out
there with a fish ain't biting yeah
we're out yeah um there's some called
Berkeley Berkeley PowerBait which is
great chartreuse green is probably my
favorite color wait so you use cat food
too right yes is that for catfish I know
for just any kind of fish that was
interested in who told you get kibbles
and bits like look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude but wet cat food in the river jump
on these [ __ ] forts this is dry
campus this is dry you can't fish a wet
cat food man this is dry cat food and uh
yeah we just struggled man it was just a
real struggle you didn't get a catfish
in the DMS nothing ugh no fish nothing
uh it was tough man god Oregon's
beautiful though huh oh so beautiful man
they said oh dear everywhere deer come
right up in the backyard you have a
little something have a banana or
something shoot them bit no why would
you we would draw pictures of them dying
and stuff but we didn't we didn't shoot
him it was like a neighborhood kind of
area was it quiet up there nice so quiet
when things open oh good a restaurant
yep went to a Mexican restaurant Oh si
Senor
damn Mexican Oregon no I want to be but
I'll take it at this point
no stated it was uh it was definitely
some of the worst Mexican food I've ever
had but you come by the [ __ ] shop
Casa tonight it's Taco Tuesday
[ __ ] girls make it right now
come on over Doug Taco Tuesday alright
I'll see you there yeah what else was
fun it was just good man it was fun it
was real relaxing nice to be out there
huh yeah do you sleep in tents oh you go
to a hotel
sup inside sup inside we rented a UH
like a house up there damn you fancy so
yeah this is my friend's family so we
just stayed up there should have called
cam Haynes
he lives up there he lives up the hill
to ran through that river and [ __ ]
picked up all the fish damn yeah you
know terminal I just know him through
Instagram no he's great yeah yeah I uh I
probably should have I wish I would have
done more stuff up there what did i do
man what you got so do you went to that
shitty Mexican restaurant yeah I went to
a Mexican restaurant make some
restaurant enchiladas no no you know
right standard [ __ ] no no no no um would
I have steak and spinach enchiladas mmm
enchiladas enchiladas yes standard so
they were good man but what else
happened up there not too much man just
chillin huh yeah a lot of whites a lot
of people killing you know we're getting
a lot of white oh yeah even yeah they
even had a couple black dudes in white
face up there oh yeah very rare smart
when you think about it yeah definitely
I mean it checks out something boys them
to them 40 yeah now can't figure out
where to get a haircut real I told god
he got one yeah you got that and I got
my cut in a garage over in Reseda last
week he said he sent me a picture of him
get his haircut in the garage was like
dog I'm out of [ __ ] barber son bro he
was at a quinceanera do where you got
your
see who goes where'd you get a haircut
at Mexico might as well been damn dude
you got to see this picture look at that
that's awesome
oh yeah this lady and her husband set up
a salon they set up a salon in the
garage up there and receipt off that off
the 101 over there up near Winnetka damn
she did a good job I had to finish it up
I mean you look exactly the same
you think I don't what do they do when
they cut your hair I've never been like
damn do you hear cut oh I defendant I
had to tighten it up on this side this
side was good this secondary but she's
all psych now oh she was nice I have to
sneak my [ __ ] in they did not want
pictures
really dude I'll tell you this second of
all tell brother my brows on point I
woke up like that now well black people
oh yeah although I did they don't touch
the top my hair they only do fades so
tons of black people now bring that back
up please Nick if you notice endless and
the walk when he sent me this picture I
said bro you have to be in Mexico that
go up a that green color paint is only
in Mexico it's actually called Tijuana
green is somebody in your family has to
be hella Mex gonna even have a can do
that places there's only there's Mexican
soccer on the TVs it's only Mex and
there's no English being spoke I gotta
show them a picture of what I want yeah
cuz they don't understand at all yeah
nothing that Mickey - only you come in
the back door and tell me I'll tell you
off here yeah I'm not trying it them
boys shut down it really really it's all
they thought oh yeah they were
struggling in nineteen barbers us the
only dude in there really they're just
fightin each other's hair - hell yeah on
each other yeah that was cool I like the
Ultimate Fighter bar oh yeah oh audience
you have to sneak that [ __ ] in for fear
she knows daily here got Mexico it may
be where la when a couple rounds of
Brutus the barber beefcake man damn
give me that Philly face yeah man you
got that fade looking good thanks doggy
so Oregon man I'm going to Houston
Thursday oh yeah it's right now Mike on
the road dog a little house really yeah
Houston Papa where you want a Houston
improv yeah wow I love that place - I
dig it
it's fun I love Texas inking Oh Texas is
jus mendin see our new merch is sold
right out of Houston h-town dude they
should all we should bring some merch
Bobby over to the show it's not a bad
idea but it's available now we'll let
everybody know it's available now yeah
the King in the sting website and you
got the website up Nick bring it up for
them folks would you know if we have an
active website but we should what's he
gonna tell you he said I don't know we
got a website you know we do they just
redid it
Oh would you move to Texas what I'm a
sexist yeah would a love Texas man I've
thought about moving a lot recently man
it's been since I've been places like
and just like enjoying my life more just
in Utah went to Oregon just the quality
of life is just a little bit more
relaxed and if I make two dollars in
Texas
I keep two dollars yeah if I make two
dollars in LA I keep one dollar yeah it
is kind of crazy man hmm okay I mean the
taxes are just crazy it's crazy but also
the government here is crazy
it's it look I agree man it says it's
squirrely bro you know it's like me not
moving weird to go other places and then
come back in like oh this place is like
you can't do everything you want to do
right now you know yeah you throw in the
traffic oh yeah it's ACTA it's
definitely a hectic place to live man
mm-hmm yeah you told us nice
I mean Oregon was nicest but then I just
wonder how much we couldn't week how
much work could we do you know I guess
you could still travel and do work
yeah you still travel you'd still do
king of stink pretty easily yeah how's
that gonna unless hear about this
Brendon I know you're down to know if
I'm down to move - yeah - yeah that's
true if you and I move the same place
you know I'm saying that's a good point
oh yeah but then on this past weekend I
would only be able to have you as a
guest all the time I can give you other
guests from access you can fly but yeah
there's tongue guests in Texas you could
fly guests in mm-hmm I love that I'm
gonna think about and people would come
there to perform you could even be a
guest then hey come be a guest buddy yep
you're here then corner dogs something
to think about dog you know nerds on my
tour I'm doing those think boy bike club
meetings we got 200 riders in Spokane
really oh yeah I don't know if the
trails ready for that a lot away yeah 20
or 30 people that's 40,000 pounds of
weight isn't it - 200 times 200 yeah
yeah a lot of people on the track
there's gonna be a slab Alliance
everything just a lot of meat in here
like a Philly cheesesteak at Chili's
just go down the high it open up [ __ ]
Chili's is all I'm saying man them
[ __ ] are open cuz when I was like
Arab restaurants open Houston some fans
sent me a [ __ ] live video him and
Chili's you I thought there's a [ __ ]
Korn concert that's really soon this
thing was slapped and they ran our baby
back ribs oh really yeah
oh man I can't believe they killed
babies for that [ __ ]
that's unbelievable dude yeah but he
knew something good was in him but every
time I see a baby I said damn boy slice
your little ass up yep it's a meal yeah
Jen I like catching catfish though man I
definitely realize you catch anything
okay you can catch any bait and catch a
catfish choppers are easy yeah for sure
you can use just junk yep
yeah put a dam a little frito on there
dog you need to caught some crawfish you
just caught some [ __ ] hot dog and
they clean you on the hot dog he's
reeling [ __ ] in oh yeah you can get
something on a hot dog I mean catfish
you can catch anything on it really but
those up these are the fish up in Oregon
man or smart there you see a fish go by
with a little smart whitefish get real
urban you that's Oregon a nutshell fish
dude yeah there they got some [ __ ]
real trout kokanee or something they got
it
Oconee yeah it's like it's like a salmon
trout thingy yeah HM where can I go to
[ __ ] catch some salmon hitters when
they jump up River backwards you can oh
the closest place effing in San
Francisco they do there's some trout are
some salmon runs every now and then you
have to time it though that sounds like
a game eat yeah just go to a club called
upstream stream
DJ tonight wine club up straight club up
scream you just wait the men come to you
oh man oh my god dude it's hard to keep
all this mass hot it's really hard you
know it's tough dude it's ya know it's
tough I'm telling you right now that
when I'm telling you is really tough and
see it's a struggle to talk about it but
it's hard to keep an erection as I get
older
is it really yeah I don't know it's hard
are you trying to catch fish me keep an
erection
oh man
good it's hard to get that hot long one
going either way
what catfish don't work for either yeah
man well let's see but the thing is
Brannon it's not just you man you know
40% of men by age 40 struggle from not
being able to get and maintain erect
that makes me feel better there's
nothing worse when you got that limp
noodle it's like what's wrong with that
thing why does it look like that why is
it so big and long but drowsy yeah a
million excuses oh yeah I used to have
to do the thing where I would put a
popsicle stick next to it and tie it
next to it you know what's up what's
this sleepy anaconda doing the bedroom
you know I used to get that all the time
yeah what's this whole sleepy treat over
here what I'm telling you about now then
is him think oh they can help you man
Helms connects you with real licensed
doctors you're not just getting the word
on the street you're not just getting
one of chins old ancient you know uh you
know Far Eastern remedies you're getting
real licensed doctors you're getting
fda-approved you know we're not talking
about that kratom powder to get your
dick my passion naw man we don't about
real [ __ ] here bro prescription
solutions backed by science and it's
really affordable to me American science
we're talking about pharmaceutical
products to treat erectile dysfunction
no painful injections whoa I've had
those man I was just talking about on
this past weekend do they inject you got
a for like five hours you got to sit
there and make sure it works
damn you do you do the long harrowing it
is harrowing dude sick needle so scary
yeah dick needle do they have to or they
have to like kind of not tie your legs
down when they do it but they got to
keep you have you moving yeah damn rough
times it's rocky but not anymore man now
all you got to do is answer a few quick
questions and if it gets approved by a
doctor the product is shipped directly
to your door to your noodles dent in
your damn dick piece yeah some days are
over try him today start with a free
online go-to for hims calm /kk ts5
that's right that's fo r hims com /k 80s
and the number five prescription
products are subject to doctor's
approval and require an online
so stationed with a physician who will
determine if the prescription is
appropriate
remember that's for hams comm slash Katz
5c website for full details and safety
information dude I can't believe you put
a needle on your dick I didn't
amande it got your mama's on it oh and
look she's texting faster than ever now
no your mom's about to answer the Tour
de France
oh she's texting faster she's texting
faster she different languages
oh she's complaining about stuff that
she never used to complain about she's
really active the world's a lot more
green when you got athletic greens in
your bloodstream yup it's the one thing
Brennan the only thing that health
expert dietician athletes and top
performers agree on is that perfect diet
doesn't exist right just supplement it
you have to I thought greens alternate
daily all in one health drink with 75
vitamins for your dome piece yep but
these aren't a lot of time you go to the
vegetable area to go to the produce area
in your market and you see a couple
vegetables all of them yeah and take
your mask off you cough on the broccoli
you see a carrot over there hanging out
with the radishes breath yeah ain't that
right this is real top-of-the-line stuff
these are vegetables that would rent win
a race if they were in them yeah it's
delivered in powder form and it's and
you mix it with water athletic greens
requires less capsules has superior
absorption hmm and doesn't include any
binders or fillers you're not getting a
bunch of you know if there's no
frito-lay some real stuff man they don't
compromise on ingredients and source and
Scouten free dairy free keto paleo vegan
friendly no harmful chemicals none of
that stuff man but it Roth you're taking
steps towards a healthier lifestyle or
an athlete pushing for better
performance athletic greens takes the
guesswork out Jeremy why not class today
and he said athletic greens calm /ke 80s
and get our special offer which is 20
free travel packs valued at $79 with
your first purchase
that's athletic greens calm /ka
t-s raise the green
I want to be your loser pay big deal
well last week we can't wear skirt and
we didn't see anything but a lot of
creeps were meant to commenting
commenting on it so we asked her if she
wanted to share some of her creepier
whether the and where do they comment on
cat's kurta there was like YouTube
comments but that dander yeah but then
we just asked to see her DMS and she was
cool with it and she shared some of the
weirder I like how YouTube will censor
us or D monetize this for talking about
gay dudes and San Fran and salmon but
then let the comments go rampant that's
freedom of speech man I don't do what
the thing
yeah but the scum of the earth is on
there so I don't know if Kat would want
to read them I would rather not be
recorded saying these things probation
violates many orders Nick abiding by for
me once
so this gentleman says he wants to be he
says I want to be your loser pay pig do
you have a paypal Loki want to be your
Twitter whatsapp a pig though he
basically just wants to give me money oh
so you want you to be his sugar baby
kind of but just like there's nothing
really in it for him other than to give
me man
oh you accept the money it makes him
feel some sort of should we do this sir
I don't just send you money he has zero
followers so that's a bad some people
will send me these things through burner
accounts it's not their actual account
oh also them as trolls yeah keep going
burner that the Comedy Store this is a
[Laughter]
yes this is one of my personal favorites
he says can I slurp oatmeal out of your
ass and he said he used to send me this
once every like week or so god dammit I
like this guy
first of all though the word word slurp
makes me feel sick
why do you say slurp oh my god oh my ass
is away a gentleman with that slurp we
kind of degenerate uses the word slur no
I gentlemen be like a good day miss
what's up the rear menu today with a
little sugar
I like that rear menu can i slurp
oatmeal out of your ass this guy is a
real foger God apparently works at the
pawn stars shop he looks like he
definitely plays um he looks like he
probably plays Center on a little person
back the newest member of pod stars dude
go straight is [ __ ] pon de stars
lives in a small body of water and eat
cat food well if it's steel-cut oats man
those are really good at lower your
class eating ass and oatmeal as a
balanced breakfast this one's my
favorite arts this guy he starts off by
saying a likio but clean for real for
real
oh sorry i met for real for real oh good
thing he corrected him I said oh my god
I'm so out of turn here oh my god sorry
I mean for real for real and this guy is
do we know anything about this guy or
who is he he seems like that help he
seems really out picture he seems
outlandish
these trolls what if you dog though in
the pillars of the hog but if that's
just his owner that's the best often
feel like anybody's but that's what they
do
oh all dogs lick ass we know this yeah
this has got to stop and they all don't
go to heaven don't get it twisted yeah
and first of all this dog is already
obviously dating a male crossing guard
we can get a tightening picture on that
guy yeah no scent and a basic 11:00 at
night what do you think he was doing
when he sent that cat an 11 yeah he
probably probably just finished watching
King this thing yeah that's what we're
gonna say he's like here we go Thursday
night saw you in the dress
what's this oh this was a comment on one
of my photos this guy says you told my
grandpa killing half of your people in
the war to get you to come to America
well worth the mandate and without a
memorial bags if that was the bonus
points for this man if the Memorial Day
and also that's a goddamn American if
I've ever seen a man a WBUR Rs 1 1 1 2
way to go man how about cat with the
quickness one minute she got that screen
shot in case this guy who had any
regrets
killing half your people more to get you
to come to America oh yeah this is 9,000
a fiancee we got one more this one's
probably the bluest but I don't know I'm
sure you're keeping it PG for a friend I
made sure not to show the two explicit
ones ok dick pics oh yeah show those to
me again just show it drawing maybe of
them
this guy says I would suck your dad's
dick if I could smell your fart what
that one's borderline
what I log on the show I don't know too
much damn bouquet are before yeah let's
call these people this kind of stuff I'd
love to get a real picture of Bo or 94
yeah just offer it look just keep it
chill man no before I sit this mom the
hell are you doing that they all
generally kind of look the same though I
will say oh we have a photo they
generally have a look the ghost of
Christmas past this is this is the last
cameo that Jerry Sloan ever did Jeff
hornacek looks like [ __ ] another
transfusion Bryan Callen be in Houston
this week I like they supporting
Brennan's other endeavors though there's
a chance right Friday but this guy sent
in this has nothing to do with cat he
sent in a video he's just a fan and he
wanted to do his own segment flaunt my
paw big fan of the show I'm Laurie and
I'm 92 years old Wow a rap artist I rap
with my boy Frank we're in quarantine
right now so he's not here we're gonna
submit ourselves to plot my paw Brendan
you look like the kind of kid that would
call out who [ __ ] their pants by your
[ __ ] in your beautiful beautiful fella
right there huh and what would you catch
this kind of guy on what they would use
to catch this fella I would say
typically just prunes perfect huh yeah I
like that throw a couple graham crackers
that becoming this room right now
open-water prunes right yeah this was
actually they they did this before King
in this thing but he was like this is
just like a sample of what we do
I'm not mad at I do I'm not mad either
man hope they celebrate it yeah let them
live their life survive the Civil War
the Black Plague and now hopefully
Corona dog oh those guys are doing it
man some [ __ ] man you guys have been
through a lot man those guys are how old
90 years old 75 and 90 too young that's
gonna be you and Brian 100% young got
flirting with that older the young dudes
obviously trying to freakin get laid I
bet one of them is by the old guy right
I mean I don't know I feel like at that
age this is an ad for farmers only that
one egg on the left that's pretty nice
body on him yeah consider his hand in a
[ __ ] oh one two look at his hand
yes I want that thing tickling your back
no you want backdraft tickle your
[ __ ] back to see me do a trick with
these matches Firehouse Subs over they
[Laughter]
part of your body
daddy's so he's at home mostly the
zombie Judi has gangrene his [ __ ] arm
mr. goddamn mind is gay gangrene
[Laughter]
maybe they'll wrap they lived
yeah rap about that hot rap about that
hard reach rather the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
third-degree weekend at bernie's oh oh
man here comes someone yeah so we we're
gonna give this singing competition
another shot these are all original cat
songs that aren't raps so oh they're all
and they're all King the sting theme
yeah yeah [ __ ] sick all right
[Music]
it's a show called the king and the
stand
but my uncle flawed by your heart you
can do whatever you want
[Music]
upon their grand broke
[Music]
we go
even chins bobbling that head man you
feeling that chin I like the hot I wanna
kinda beat somebody needs to give JJ
reddick a 10-day contract is all I'm
saying
somebody's tobey maguire back in
spider-man a [ __ ] ah good job man it's
incredible yeah it was cool that guy's
playing three four inch from the terrace
yeah you get on the Venice Beach or they
get that one-man band he's the black
dude he loved the [ __ ] Sean Bulls on
his shoulders plays the sax guitar plays
the [ __ ] piano with his feet really
[Laughter]
when I was a kid I grew up on this dude
I think he died mmm I can also be Wesley
Snipes one man man in Venice Beach yeah
I grew up on this dude in the summers I
grew up in Venice
noise toss this [ __ ] body hit it all on
our going back to that what does it say
get it all on our SD store now tell me
now tell me if he's better than that
[ __ ] Brokeback tobey maguire you
let's play Michael Jackson I remember
see the feet and the drums it's Michael
Jackson right yeah
just a guy from the Howard Stern Show it
was that guy's name beetlejuice yeah see
but hopefully that's a student now any
singing might apprentice is giving me I
this makes me nervous like this guy I
think if you get past three instruments
it's too much
yeah it was a real [ __ ] when I was a kid
I thought he was this yeah he didn't now
I see this girl man he clearly a mess
before garage what are you gonna say NIT
I was just gonna say that the first one
was marked from Massachusetts Tobey
Maguire yeah I think that Venice guy was
[ __ ] homeless mastered a good job huh
yeah he was nice I was I was relaxed to
that yeah very relaxing what'd you think
of that that cat is that your kind of
guy you think kind of guy yeah any guy
who can multitask and play a harmonica
good with me you're not sliding them DMS
with a song for you I mean if he does
maybe I'll see it maybe I'll see you man
this is alley cat Zac Brown Band got
four I got that hipsters
[Music]
[Music]
bigboy my club ain't nowhere get you one
of those gray black hitters
[Music]
it looks like he works security at a
limousine service built only for tweens
he looks like you live sway to the
trucks big seat in there Wisconsin
cheese cats bringing those [ __ ] boys to
their knees
Jim's wearing a man's touch hey I was
playing hacky in the Sun I am Brandon
can't name desserts or cheese TV shows
got that CT lips ain't nothing just
Louisiana
[Music]
you got sheeps in Britain start streets
[Music]
yeah it's not bad
this leader feeling good do you play
this the next week wait man leave you
feeling yourself thank you brother
that was beautiful beautiful young man
he was great he was really good man that
guy and look at all that a hair on his
face - that's a commitment yeah what so
long as you can grow that thing you got
going didn't know it Jesus this is sucks
hey you broke it so [ __ ] mad bro
shave I can't you said you liked it
really okay you just don't want to do it
no she does she like it or not yes she
does
but I hate it that's all patch stuff is
she
it is Apache it's a little yeah I mean
I'm not one to talk my beard is not
great either but you should shave and
should be like deal with it okay yeah I
think yeah I think she maybe shave it up
I mean a haircut wouldn't kill you no I
like it you growing it out it doesn't
like bad growing it out but if you're
trying to get a haircut you gotta quit
with all this call that Corona cuz I
know a ton of barbers out there do you
do then tell me drop these names yeah I
text you all the time you won't take me
you never text I know that's right
you're right you're right whenever he
talks about my weight put on some white
and the last guy was Dan Lucille and
this is Jack hot you talked to me Dan he
had me fans her man made me proud to do
this show really yeah true that's how I
felt good call about that let's eat it
let's see you know let's see this little
Donna
boy you craziest boy don't jack off to
Wonder Woman comets or coconut Donnie's
big round from the UFC but now telling
jokes it's Joe exotic and the sample is
a little bit
with polls and his genes on his knees
too long
[Music]
you're a deep voice for kids peel all
Nana's has to belong and he's lucky that
he's still alive to see what's on the
school trying to be cool with looking at
the stick
I've got some news for you
a mistake you won't see this [ __ ] on the
news
stick Brendan says he's not gay buddy
really love shoes
there'll be a sneaker hand up oh yeah I
wish you had liked his chinny chin with
his black mask like a ninja better
[Music]
I feel like is dad saying this and he's
over kids born without a lever you know
and they grew up in the psych ward some
[ __ ] without a lever you look at the
psych ward I know how they do it man it
seems a little off it was a very joe
exotic vibe you sampled the song a
little bit I think it was the same beat
but yeah that's good that's great voice
was that deep no one no one beats that
hipster ZZ Top though this [ __ ] was fire
yeah Daniel Lucille was named Daniel
Daniel Lucille yeah nobody wants real
Daniel Lucille came through with that
hitter right there and that right end
credits for the episode oh yeah
and that one right there I feel like was
good if you're yeah if you're leaving
your wife or something driving out of
town and listen to that one but if
you're doing something else I've
listened to something else you know but
good submissions oh man those were
really good some rows you don't see in
the sting only yeah what do you think
Chan you're the musical man here I'm
what Brennan the second guy he seems he
has like an older soul countries he's
I'm friendly yeah not the big the big
boy
didn't at the end but you know I'm
getting that yeah yeah we got one two
Bay Club and one King and or sting it
less welcome here's the debate club
Theo does JP come to you from Augusta
Georgia home of the Augusta green
jackets my league baseball team and I'm
come to you with a debate club who
should feel date next Carly or Hannah
that Alabama kept fish noodle er hitter
or that Los Angeles Korean barbecue
eating dinner or that that the cream bar
you big tip he got he'll married it you
know big tick Carly was feeling you I
think that that little [ __ ] southern
belle with the knuckle deep and the
catfish is the way to go
you think he's out there yes she seemed
real nice she is bad yeah bad to the
bone that's beautiful fish - my thing
that hates or is a catfish that's true
huh hmm and she have serve up catfish
too every night catfish mm-hmm you know
this past weekend you got no fish yeah
you catch all the fish boy yeah I love
that grouper right done it's [ __ ] Oh
beat me in the face with that dirty
grouper that's what you like dang Carl
Wow percent for hot Carl I disagree wow
it's a neck-and-neck over there though
oh I can't believe they didn't go with
fish woman how do you call fish woman
what do you think Kat I think Hannah is
more of your girl now that fish hannah
with that with that southern twang that
she's bodied up and as a [ __ ] together I
know if you'd notice she's driving a
$70,000 Raptor Rock yeah Wow you might
time I mean my Paul Wow Dan she's a
first-team all baddie I thought you said
she was driving a rav4 did you tell me
that nah they'd been sad oh yeah that
one that helped her case Doug and I'm
not now hot Karl tits here no [ __ ]
slouch either
and here's chin chin Oh Hannah has a man
Oh [ __ ] was that you lying [ __ ]
no yeah we got [ __ ] catfish dude nope
that's her man maybe she just took him
out for a nice hunt does anybody want to
guess the weight of my blue cap before I
post a video hint it's not as big as my
whatever whatever does safety about the
dude know that that dude has a better
body than both of us I'm a dog oh
definitely might have better biceps and
maybe I don't think it's better nipples
you have a better ass you have better
set of tits out the back is that a
different dude no same guy with her
again because I thought there's a real
connection oh you know it's kind of sure
oh brother but I'll tell you this okay
what you can freak about my boy Ryan
shotgun Raptor he looks a little bit
like you affiliate kind of microwave and
it could be cousins for sure dude you
know what he knows his way around a
catfish it's like a neck that's true man
well look I run a catfish I do I could
catch a catfish and show that lady
what's up but I can't catch him what you
know I'm not doing it maybe we should
ask her
hot corals out there drinking that close
to our open stove yeah Carl take
advantage of situation and [ __ ] drank
seven [ __ ] what were you sipping on
soju soju
well that was chin who got her drunk and
then left and then one eye in the
[ __ ] tits man the whole time I stare
at our kids that makes more than I'm
married make sound like a little Nicki
everything
the mic hot Karl may fit Dafoe percent
Dafoe will see and you can't go wrong
with either but I don't know how it
crawled those for a job hand either [ __ ]
together dude had her [ __ ] together dude
I don't know if reaching in new large
animals mouths bro really she does what
she loves that's your point but does she
make a living doing I guess you could
sell the fish time Wow
yeah never mind that man I guess we'll
see man I sayd on a date with each of
them let us film it and see how it goes
we'll see what Hannah you mean the
backyard [ __ ] sticks in that Raptor
mud slinging oatmeal slurping laughing
yeah fish on the griddle
she cooks a lot you want deep down that
profile she cooks she's the baddest cat
Fisher catcher in the world that's her
look I think that right there is really
the tiebreaker for me is it oh you
should see if he can catfish sure
there's gonna be something on the grill
when I get home you know yeah and I
don't have to catch it you have to do
anything nice to me you know after about
three weeks of eating catfish every
night gets a little old seems like
that's all she know but you could have
catfish nuggets man catfish there's
obstacles mmm what's what's hot Karl
gonna bring to the table though she took
advantage of our friend chin here and
drink all that [ __ ] sake and barbecue
and then and then was down to go an
after-party yeah and chin left her for
his damn white mother maybe that's what
you should do with Hannah go out with
her and then come out with wife oh wow
damn pull the old catfish on her get
that big put a yeah but just what if I
just showed up with my hand down her
throat I think you have to ask for
consent first it should be okay I should
be down well you never know if I'll put
a ring in it she might
sure you never know man she lives in
Alabama though I live here she's a huge
boyfriend these are all great point
who has the word gun I think it is a AG
name these are a great point
Hana's are carly's local and single so
yeah and affliction did make a pass at
you maybe she's like I pretty sure she's
like video single holla
she's like Theo holla we'll see man
we'll see what's up my thing right now
I'm just trying to take it easy
[Laughter]
traffic right now you can get your like
no [ __ ] yeah but that traffic coming in
that traffic's picking up I'm with deal
he wants to slurp local we are moving
podcast to Houston closer closer
not huge turnout Austin ah look man
whatever happens dude I'm down for
something we'll see what happens man
we'll see we're local
I'm gonna pray about it there you go
i'ma pray about it
alright here's a white right here we'll
close it out with one King under sting
it and it's got like a supplementary
video he sent in with it it's my boy
Robbie from Barstow
what's up guys I hope you're doing well
it's Robbie from barstool and I got a
King ander sting it for you your boy Tom
Segura has been going off on
professional wrestling fans wrestlers
themselves and he just put out a press
conference as mystic Rick I don't have
you've seen this I don't know King under
sting and for me Gang Gang buzz-buzz
we Canyon sting at Toms I've got Tom and
his antics with the dodo ve or we can
esteem Pro Wrestling in general I think
Tom's antics and his character mystic
Rick I've never seen this when the
author you see this I pissed you off
yeah let's watch this
[Music]
oh no I was I meant that they're stupid
they're all beneath me you know they're
losers if they want to come you know
maybe clean up my toilet or whatever
just spit on them while they're doing it
just give me a little taste of the
mystique hey Rick you're so strong
you can even withstand the ankle lock oh
it's true it's damn true mission
accomplished there's my parrot solstice
you know we always enter the ring
together anybody wants to get the turkey
Slifer come come at me man
mr. Crick you are never down for the
count oh yes the best er was in the
best-ever whoopee just keep those jeans
high in there today you are thank you
[ __ ] rather bike in his heart is shut up
my son Calgary in all sweats Oh
everything a heart attack is because his
heart is filtering gin out of that's why
and I love him too and I say that heart
should we keep rolling your eyes I do
yours keep brawling mash it's making me
sick is fake why can't I win a big fight
sign me up
let's rehearse your fake ass is the
strongest been the best and he throws it
down in the bedroom the best my main man
mr. champ and I'm the one to take no
keep feathering it brother
Congrats on your beautiful exotic hot
one Christina's party Cody
Rivera the Spanish sizzle snake you can
get you appreciate it in your language -
Akira's remover Houston - yeah mousse
Marika reporting kitten kantha when we
get home de minimis llamo me understand
anyone of you fake-ass athletes and get
this fake punch thrown at your fake face
mister Greek in espanol no more
questions I'm late I have a caviar
tasting McLaren his hat says got Co you
notice that
do you know I just think it's messed up
I just think you know they obviously
used these older guys Ric Flair and
these guys on cam he honeydicked he
totally did man dude rich her key slicer
dude Ric Flair looks like he's full of
cheese everyone hurry hey Ric Flair
definite looks like he has he had a
strong case of gray areas cleared up
more Flair than Rick rock dude Bret the
Hitman Hart came my show in Calgary and
you know he's good to do this Hulk Hogan
bit and the owner of the Yuk Yuk's just
a man we got we got Ric Flair we got
Bret the Hitman Hart company you know
he's like God he's our staple here in
Calgary and he's WWE guy so cut the [ __ ]
with the Hulk Hogan bit tonight on the
gap right did it I think he came back
backstage and all sweats I was ago I'm
glad you dressed up but he came in he
came back and he wouldn't look at me he
just stared at my brother BAM he just
stared
literally through my brother's soul and
told old school stories wow that was
great dude that's awesome man
Bret the Hitman Hart do you super
friendly dude he was a legend bro dude
his brother Marty Jannetty Owen Owen
following our own fell off the top he's
gonna do a stunt and fell off the top
and died I remember when that happened
crazy huh I was pretty sad dude and he's
Canadian huh mm-hmm
from Calgary Calgary uh pretty this
whole family is like like a huge they're
basically like the [ __ ] JJ Watts
really yeah Wow Russian say the Mannings
he's been through it all man but yeah I
just I say what did he say King under
sting it man yeah mr. Creek nice ting it
damn I think mr. mr. mr. Rick what's his
name missing you dick or what's not
Richard I can't I'm with you I want to
ride with you here but I'm with it with
the fake sports a sport what they do is
a fake Brendon it's pretty fake Wow and
it's challenging it's tough but so is
Mickey on ice yeah yeah you know the
right we'll see what the Rat King says
yeah I think I can use em something to
say about this
retching you coming ha up the top rope
all right but make sure you rehearse it
before it's the only way to come in
brother ha he wants that [ __ ] Swiss
wheelchair I'll give it to him yeah yeah
them gears up and [ __ ] come off that
I know how to do it tips or not I'm not
taking it from some man use to aisle in
to go to UFC is out there Vernon getting
Pam spray on with garlic garlic you got
the wrong one out of my bag Oh like
steak dude get your get your fake tan
spray on oil that [ __ ] are you well
let go cheese covered body huh buddy
come off that top rope ha if you want
you get some of it too boy all right
maybe a 240 son give me a 2000 fat Rick
or whatever that guy's name whatever
that frickin mr. Grigg yeah whatever
that [ __ ] Walmart damn crossdresser
whatever his name is that frickin salt
intake Victor
I feel like Nick are your WWE fan huh I
watched a lot in the 90s that kind of
stomped to I'll tell you in the 90s and
then I grew up you know I did not know
what a dolt so we're gonna be watching
it when I was 13 I was like you grow out
of this you got a stop but how some
adults just keep on powering through it
it's real to me damn it
is it big in the Asian community
Campbell you guys hey I don't think so I
don't well but no Russell's big in Asia
they are man Jacana sure I don't think
Korean doesn't Korea does it at all
though kpop yeah yeah you guys sing in
what else all right
in drift cars and drift cars to Jeff
that's Japanese - well five a huge issue
with Asians in motion is all you put all
of Asians okay it's a couple Asians in
here no what I'm saying is you put an
Asian still somewhere they do a great
job right
Iwo Jima for example hiding in the
hillside killed I don't even know how
many people were trying to take that
Island Harbor yeah they were stationed
right but I'm just saying you get Asian
in motion that's when it gets frisky
yeah kamikazes yeah kamikaze so I'm
gonna take this plane for a spin no
you're not nikka whiskey yeah they made
that that's not yeah but that doesn't
mean you either but what I'm saying is
still Asian it's the best thing you can
have man a still Asian can make all the
right moves sure you said you put said
Asian down ahead had them downhill a
little bit then you got powered much
yeah it's just too much going on in the
in the in the wheelhouse you know crash
something I think yeah
it's just too much I think Asians are
better it's still you know from a still
position yeah Crouching Tiger remember
that movie I know I never saw the movie
though oh I didn't either man Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon yeah is it good - I
don't want you yeah I think that's like
Chinese I think okay yeah okay well but
you say in Asians in general how do you
guys feel about that though when I say
Asians in motion or more of a liability
than still Asians is that feel does that
ring a
interior I do my best work when I'm
stationed stationed there you go right
singing making music on the computer
engineering editing yep
in the best Asian f1 driver in NASCAR
dressing yeah yeah try to help you're
the best Asian stunt pilot I don't
aegeon printer even sprinting I think
it's risky trouble but also when you get
to uh what is that thing call where they
pull the thing and the thing goes oh he
shooting yeah
Asians great at skeet shooting hmm top
twenty skeet shooters let's see if
there's an Asian in it well they did
develop duck hunter so you might be onto
something
yeah that was Toshiba Toshi Toshiba
international well we could probably
tell by the names yep
top men I see any Cambodia I'm seeing
that an Indians number one yeah
inhalation Russian German Italian Sweden
no American huh okay that's up crock of
[ __ ] so hit or miss on that part okay
your point was well made though what do
you think about a cat if I say that does
that feel like it could be real Korean
there is yeah if I'm like there's some
truth the Chinese Chinese Korean and I'm
not saying that Russia also considered
Asia I just think some at this city's
overall have a little bit more acumen
for certain things
I think Asian people I think tend to be
better from us stacked you flirtin with
racism but I'm yeah I'm trying to back
up I'm gonna jump off pretty soon here
okay this trains going fast
racist town yeah you bought the ticket
so that's the crazy part but if you look
right here on these skeet shooters
Korea's ahead of us a right and will try
to end rushes ahead I'm a stew out there
so right there man back there just goes
to tell you something
damn and they're young born in
yang Yang
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Americans ain't on here that's what
I'm telling you you freak that we're not
good at that kind of stuff we're more
like alright let's do it in motion no I
just think that other examples you got
was I thought and look we had one guy on
there sherry Timothy with her on the
state mm-hmm the only American named
sherry Timothy because we give a [ __ ]
about that sport ski shootings a real
deal man damn who's that little skeet
the third one in there yeah
what exactly is it that's Tim cherry
right there the boy can shoot a gun
I'm point shoot is when something's
flies out in front of me and you shoot
it Oh
prior to us a but you see a lot of there
are a lot of Asian train conductors or
no hmm in Asia yeah I don't think in the
States or around the world
hmm in Japan there's a train conductor
that I think is a cat C not is the
kindest even Asian bike riders know yes
the Tour de France you what sort of fail
okay yeah yeah they're amateur but
they're also in the Guinness Book of
World Records is that one Asian person
that it's 17 people on the bicycle
number that picture in the Guinness Book
of World Records you guys to love that
book so good no Indian dude have the
longest nails oh yeah yeah Wallace lady
Ted for hanging out yeah
tallest lady yeah was it yes you told
over that picture oh then that look fun
yeah tell us man I guess I want to be
the guy in yellow that's you on the back
for sure in that picture you go to that
picture yeah I don't wanna be the guy in
yellow not me oh me the guys won't be
the guy in blue dude with the jeans on
driving that [ __ ] I don't be the other
dude holding the dude in yellow date to
dick trunk the trunk brah
nah man we go nuts to butts right if you
look closely there's a guy in green in
between because I'm coming out and nuts
the buts only not playing this game bro
this is insane see that's kind of stuff
I'm talking about man oh they said
another world record this is an Indian
team they have their current record of
motorcycles but but then there are the
things that's [ __ ] planks on the side
well how's you suppose getting 20 people
on that [ __ ] that build planes is
[ __ ] stupid
fifty-eight men rode on it I wonder if
they take off the sides once they get
going
no they have to right
no they're just right like okay that's a
trolley in San Fran right oh [ __ ] bro
they did it pretty easy it really did
not like or I let's see that I guess
yeah that's I like that old-school real
move Yamaha to sponsor them boys yeah
that guy there's a couple guys I don't
face in the way that it's going that's
the scariest thing going trunk the trunk
bro that's how you sleep dude that's the
bunch that's it got it
mm-hmm all right man well good to be
back in here man glad you made it safe
yeah good to be back man I'm glad to be
back I'm gonna get stuff to get some
fishing tips from chin yeah shoot I'm up
dude give me hahaha I didn't think about
it Oh figured you were catching fish it
was harrowing out there embarrassing -
pretending you're catching something
tell your girl you beg your ready
tonight girl yeah we there me jumping is
heavy catch zero and then you go to a
Mexican restaurant that's in poor again
she's all way to go Theo talking all
that [ __ ] they'd be jumping tonight girl
I hope you hungry is that wet catfish it
sure is
you'd have lots of shade eerie rods and
reels - was tough go I got it I got to
make a more valid effort next time you
got a dude you got it I talk to fish
locally though innit Jen there's nothing
here
it sucks la Orange County sucks still
going fish right Joe won't you fish off
like the Santa Monica Pier for homes and
homeless [ __ ] not the pier but the
actual burnt the beach the surf wait
your teeth doesn't a lot but he gets a
boat and he goes out yeah he was way
harder oh no he catches some crazy [ __ ]
tuna lorem when you get them if I catch
it that's one of my favorite things to
do
killer right there Anita right there you
all you eat those sashimi right there no
I actually cook it well those don't you
eat it right on the beach I don't think
it's down on the beach cuz it's been
really tough to catch him on the beach
but other places but you slice it right
fresh I know how to gut a trout like
really really fast texter [ __ ] the
how-to video from chin if we can catch a
trout did he get flagged on YouTube do
it yeah you know they do that too don't
see monetize if you show you killing the
fish you just blank it out real quick
and how do you take these fish out chin
you slap them on the boat I like to take
a rock and hit in the head you take this
rod in this way you hold it bang BAM and
it's just instantly like shock stems so
would you rather get knocked out and
then someone open up your guts or would
you rather have someone just open up
your guts we talked about fish neither
why wouldn't you is there a more can you
I guess you can't drown am i stupid dry
them in the air you could just let them
that's like that's that's torture I
think you'll be torture yeah you mean
let them gasp yeah good waterboard them
get some answers out of waterboard you
think those wet [ __ ] don't have some
answers fish on the boat waterboard that
stupid [ __ ] trout yeah that borrows
some [ __ ] mix duct tape yeah borrow
some annexed duct tape dynasty all right
we got new cast merch to let Sutton you
guys know the website is up and running
I should as fire shits fire and it's
coming right out of Houston take Hass
and you're there this weekend yeah Doug
that's crazy man back on the road
I know definitely in Corona well by
Corona I mean a six-pack ice cold holla
dang you got it
Chappelle where will you be anywhere
I'll be at my house jump-roping there
you go yeah I'm looking for a barber
barber you gonna tell me after yeah I
got you yeah you're real you want come
to Spokane with me yeah definitely I get
your hair cut DM any of those guys back
cat or no no I'll oftentimes screenshot
it and then send it out to a bunch of
friends I would like to be included in
that group chat yeah you only want to
see the dicks that's the thing I'm not
trying to look at dick pics that's fair
hey I won't open it
everybody's fishing for something bro do
you tap it once so you get that blur tap
it once just so I can see kind of like
what I'm working with and then I'll
decide whether to click again or not do
you look at him no it's something else
if it doesn't look like it be a dick it
might be something funny got it it could
be our boys [ __ ] bird are somebody's
dick in a hot dog bun they put mustard
and ketchup like Holly like a bratwurst
locate American too like super American
cinema more okay
okay after my birthday so it's like a
late night think of that I salute that -
dude that's freaking beautiful look
Brendan and do fighter and wait I gotta
go in and go hard in the paint I do not
think I am and Flo black rifle coffee
I'm ready to go
I need a sponsor I am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts Flo is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls letter Instagram famous Tim
hungry like I'm fresh off keto seeing
red like Andrew Santino every song I hit
like the great Bambino Brennan a the
case Oh indicate Cerritos but
everything's gonna be fine and hate on
me I do not mind
hey Theo looking like the type of dudes
I got a case of Mountain Dew on him at
all times
they sliding into my TMP's a couple of
them try but couldn't beat him quit
playin like Nintendo DS you don't want
the smoke like Joey Diaz meaning you're
edible just got my eyebrows threaded and
I'm feeling incredible burning sun hit
me up he said it's too loud in the club
can you pick me up King and then sting
me King and then sting King and then
sting bee sting Rat King
yeah King and the sting yeah King and
then sting got that Spees in the trap
got that cheese on a string yeah
and then sting a king and the sting yes
King and that sting bee sting Rat King
a king in the sting yeah King indistinct
got that Spees is a trap got that cheese
on a string
[Music]